[Music]
what could possibly drive the
mild-mannered timothy mcgee from ncis to
take extreme measures that could put his
career on the line keep watching to find
out with countless crime procedural
dramas on the air the jag spin-off ncis
remains one of the most popular and it's
not difficult to see why the cbs series
now in its 19th season follows the
special agents of the naval criminal
investigative services as they work to
solve cases related to the navy and
marine corps the show focuses primarily
on investigating crime and bringing
those responsible to justice but it's
not all business all the time each
episode makes sure to devote some time
to the personal lives of its team
members and explore the unique bonds
they've developed in the field bless you
what are you my priests
curse you considering that the show has
been on the air since september of 2003
it should come as no surprise that the
cast list has seen its share of changes
over the years with veteran actor mark
harmon stepping back from the series as
of october 2021 that leaves only two
original ncis agents in the spotlight
former medical examiner donald mallard
and senior field agent timothy mcgee the
latter specializes in cyber security and
computer crime and tends to stand out
from his colleagues as a dork after all
he writes mystery novels based on their
job on occasion however mcgee will
surprise everyone with a dramatic
attitude shift by asserting himself when
a scenario calls for it like in season 4
episode 9 of ncis where he makes an
uncharacteristically drastic move that
jeopardizes everything he's worked for
and briefly strains most of his personal
and professional relationships the
episode titled twisted sister features
timothy mcgee's hot-headed sibling sarah
arriving at her older brother's
apartment and it doesn't take long to
figure out that something's terribly
wrong she's dazed disheveled and covered
in blood dropping a bombshell right out
of the gate i think i killed someone too
as anyone would be tim's taken aback by
this revelation but he doesn't allow his
emotions to get the best of him instead
he lets her in so she can wash off the
mysterious blood and get some rest in
the morning he calls out of work six so
he can attempt to solve the case without
the rest of the ncis team however when
visiting her college he realizes his
colleagues are investigating a dead
sailor on campus prompting him to flee
the scene though he was certain that
sticking his neck out for his sister was
the right call mcgee soon realizes that
his career threatening choices couldn't
remain a secret forever in this episode
tim seems to make every wrong move for
the sake of protecting sarah after all
she's his sister and despite how guilty
she appears the last thing he wants is
for her life to fall to pieces he does
wisely suggest involving ncis but she
refuses and it isn't until they get
caught trying to sort the situation out
themselves that the truth comes out this
causes everyone to finally work together
to retrace sarah's steps and get some
answers as if he wasn't already in hot
water mcgee's dedication to clearing his
sister's name goes too far when even
after receiving surprising leniency from
ncis despite withholding evidence he
snaps at director jennifer shepard and
quits on the spot of course gibbs once
again proves himself as the glue holding
the ncis team together by convincing him
to stay once his temper is cooled a bit
but it's a genuinely shocking moment all
the same this isn't a side of mcgee that
viewers see too often so when it does
come out you know that something's amiss
thankfully everything works out for the
mcgee family in the end but getting
sarah's complex predicament taken care
of was no easy feat to some extent it's
plain to see why tim's usual
level-headedness totally disappeared in
twisted sister but it's difficult to
deny that he overstepped his bounds on
this particular occasion
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
ncis are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]